so good afternoon I mean a hutch Nicki
in the user interface group and today
I'm going to talk briefly about how you
can work with documents on the cloud
specifically focusing on working with
them inside of the desktop products
either Mathematica or wolfram desktop
just as a quick tour we're going to talk
about what's currently their interface
wise we're going to talk briefly about
what kind of notebook functions are
aware of cloud objects and then the real
meat of this talk is actually going to
be about what's coming so much like most
cloud-enabled applications the most
common way that you actually end up
interacting with them is is actually
opening modifying and then saving
content directly back to it and the
simplest form of that of course is the
generic old-fashioned open and save
dialog which we have for the cloud if
you've never seen it it supports login
we have login support in the product and
they're located right there the open and
save dialog or themed to match the the
cloud styling but the but the usage
patterns are the same we don't do a
whole lot of maintenance so there's no
you know like oh I want to rename files
inside of it we're not trying to
replicate finder or explore inside of
our product originally we tried it and
decided that was a little bit of
overkill if you're interested in seeing
that happen in the future I'd be
interested in hearing about that
afterwards but the only thing that is
truly useful is for being able to modify
your cloud storage directly is we give
you the ability to save sorry in the
save dialog we give you the ability to
create a new folder the real interesting
is the activity monitor oh hmm actually
i'll leave that there that's actually
fortuitous the the activity monitor all
the interactions that the front end has
with the cloud happens asynchronously in
a queue so whenever you go to open the
document or save content back to the
cloud it actually happens off of a queue
so it can happen on a somewhat
maintainable schedule without
overloading for instance your own
network connection or you know if
everybody decided to save the exact same
thing at the same time then we don't
take the cloud down with it as well it's
also the place where as you can see it
actually ends up reporting errors so
that way you can actually maintain you
can indicate to the system what you're
trying what you would like to do here
either trying again in this instance or
you can actually abort it I took the
bold step we're going to try it maybe it
was because I turned it off earlier the
the interesting bit about this is is
that on Windows and Linux in version 10
we actually shut the application down
when you've closed all of your windows
but if this is still syncing that would
actually end up in terminating the
process in the middle so you would never
have your data finished uploading so the
cloud activity monitor basically is
there to keep the system going to allow
the data to continue to upload and
finish out otherwise it ends up having a
very odd experience of you thought you
saved it you shut your laptop you come
and use it on a different machine and
then all of a sudden all your data isn't
there anymore so from interface
interface perspective it's pretty
standard from a UI point of view inside
the document we just added a few bit of
error handling messaging it lets you
know that the the front-end knows if you
have active internet connections and it
will let you know that you're in that
it's impossible to save document
because you lack Internet connectivity
it also report errors in that place as
well and we have this cute little bubble
at the bottom just to let you know that
saves are pending oft in the background
as well in case you don't have the
Activity Monitor around but the real
interesting stuff is actually the the
notebook functions in the language that
we can use with cloud objects so the
obvious one of course is notebook open
you know given an arbitrary cloud object
you can actually directly open the
notebook in the front end modify it to
your heart's content you can then
actually call notebook save on that
notebook object and it will then send it
back but as I mentioned it is
asynchronous which means that the data
itself will not be sent to the server by
the time the function is finished that's
something to be aware of and we don't we
didn't have the two argument form in 10
for notebook information we made a few
tweaks along the way we added two new
fields to the result one is basically
storage class which describes whether or
not the notebook is backed locally on
your file system or you're in the cloud
and if its cloud-based object it of
course has a URI field that lets you
know the cloud object that's actually
backing it but that's what we currently
have which is admittedly a little on the
thin and so for some of the stuff that
we're doing in the future as I mentioned
we did saving being a synchronous is
probably one of the more difficult
things to work with I acknowledge with
the biggest problem just being how do I
know when it's even done so we added
interesting the line wrapping so we
added a current value that will actually
tell you the status of the queue this
will base
you can query the system to find out if
there's any tasks running in general you
can find out specifically if there's any
open tasks or any particular save tasks
and then you can also filter this not
only on you know as globally but also
for a particular notebook so for
instance kind of the idea behind this is
I have a an application that I've built
in a document that basically goes
through and generates a whole bunch of
other things and it's putting all those
other things up to the cloud you can
actually have you I in your document
that actually indicates you know hey I'm
generating these and now I'm saving them
off in the background and you can do
that you can do that relatively strict
simply here's just a quick little dirty
demo that I put together it's just
basically opening one that's already
there re saving it and then it's going
to sit there and show you the show you
the state of the notebook in progress as
its saving so that's how you can you can
programmatically indicate the status of
you know any document that you happen to
be generating we also added a way so you
can actually tell if I actually you can
tell with notebook information but this
is an easier way to tell to be able to
query for this in interfaces the first
thing that I thought of that we would
possibly use this for is if we had
something like a property's field or you
know like tab or palette or whatever you
want to call it for a particular
notebook if it was written in high level
what we would want to do is we would
want to know you know if this is a
cloud-based notebook we would end up
showing metadata ABCD if it is a if it's
you know a notebook that's backed in the
file system we would show metadata you
know efg
you know this is it it's useful if
you're if you're actually trying to
build applications that are going to
handle differently depending on where
the source and the destination are going
to be there's a quick little example for
it as you can see this one's actually
stored locally just in case my network
didn't work but the real but the real
crux was dealing with that thing that I
kind of hand waved around a little bit
earlier which was the two argument form
of notebook save which is arguably in a
system where we pride ourselves in being
able to generate documents in a
programmatic fashion our documentation
build system is done this way you know
it to have an asynchronous function is
exceedingly difficult to work with so
notebook save we're extending it so that
it works with the two argument forms so
you can actually specify a cloud object
as the destination and it works
synchronously so you're guaranteed that
the data is actually going to be there
it's just infinitely easier to work with
it that way and once of course you are
doing saving the next avi in document
generation the next obvious bit that you
want to think about is normally you want
to end up deploying it you know normally
create this content and then just let it
sit there this normally get someplace it
goes someplace else so we extended CDF
deploy this can now target the cloud
directly you could do this in 10 it's
just ugly I wrote this mice when I wrote
that I was like you and so now it's a
little easy it's a little it's a little
more straightforward a little more
concise to actually see what's going on
the nice thing we didn't we haven't
decided to make the to set the
permissions for cloud objects and deploy
because it's just too I think it's a
little too um what's the right word for
it I don't think it's the right decision
to just a blunt carte blanche set
permissions against of any one type so
in so instead that's done manually still
but the nice thing is is that you know
you can just deploy you know what you
were deploying before you can actually
just target it straight to the cloud and
avoid this whole entire nonsense of
copying files and deleting temporaries
which is just kind of a pain to work
with I think well I think what I don't
want to do is I don't want to have it
have a default of you know it would be I
mean just assuming that it's going to be
public it could be there it could set it
but then you know it would just be
whatever you specify and if not its left
private and the default is I think more
along the line of what I would go for
this is very much still mmm flow so if
there's things that along the way that
that you think would be it's in the
cloud storage yeah but it's just private
for you you don't rewrite the whole
you're not rewriting the whole thing be
it's it's a separate transaction yes
yeah I think even internally that would
be a you know that I think the rest
service isn't enough by itself i think
that's two steps so so that's a ploy so
okay so we have a whole bunch of content
that's on the web that's up on the cloud
you know normally you want to link to it
of some type so a couple of the
extensions that we're making for this
the the obvious thing you know we had
notebook open but no but locate didn't
work so that was extended notebook
located is actually the function that
basically powers the documentation
system so you can have that jump
straight to
I object and then of course once you
have notebook locate hyperlink is
basically built on top of it so
hyperlink was an obvious extension one
of the interesting things about
hyperlink is you know we have the setup
and if you give it a cloud object it
actually goes to the web version of it
I'm not actually convinced yet that
that's the right behavior for them um
but you know maybe that will change me
that well maybe that becomes optional it
can go to two different places who knows
I'd be interested to know what you think
about it and then of course there was a
few other a few people internally even
that we're asking about how to use cloud
objects with system open and and that
was pretty obvious because the response
was always well just do first of cloud
object and then give it to system open
and normally diving into objects leads
to code that's not going to last over
time due to version changes so we
extended system open to at least do the
right thing and that will open in
whatever web browser you happen to have
selected on the machine so that you know
that's great that's you know but this is
all like stuff that's in the product
itself and it goes out the really
interesting bit is I have it on the
cloud somewhere and I want someone to
get to it so the real interesting bit is
this new abdus new URL custom protocol
that we have for it mathematical Wolfram
desktop both register for this and
basically how this works is that you
have the URL for a cloud object you
basically rip the HTTPS off of it and
then you give it this Wolfram plus cloud
object thing and what this lets you do
basically is you can send someone for
instance in email
right and go hey I have this document
that I just deployed earlier and it's
public so you don't even you know
anybody can look at it here is the web
address right but you can also do you
can also do not only is there this web
address but here's this other address
too and if you do that here's an example
if I hit this one this one that is just
going to open it in place well maybe
depending on if I network is going to
work or not says it's working but it
ain't going anywhere hmm that makes for
a really bad demo but this war um this
is what happens when you click on the
link that has the the Wolfram plus cloud
object URL protocol at the front instead
this will actually open directly in the
product if they have it installed no you
know go and open this thing you know go
into this web page and download this
file and then open it you know open your
app and then you know and then remember
where you saved it on disk this is just
you know click the link hit allow this
probably won't download for some odd
reason we're just not going to be happy
that's unfortunate ah it finally did so
it opened directly no no asking no
questions just go which i think is
actually really useful I think it's so
useful I've actually debated internally
myself of just having a way for regular
notebooks to work this way just because
it's so useful but it's so obvious to
just download you know go save as
but for but for cloud objects in this in
this structure this thing is is really
nice and easy to use and you can use it
yourself you can put it up on internal
web pages you know so you have your
large documents that you're sharing with
lots of people you can have you know
basically a catalog of all of these
things and you can just go bang bang
bang and you can choose which way you
want to view it if you want to view it
in a web browser great you want to view
it in mathematica great you want to view
it potentially in the Wolfram cloud app
on your iPad great you know no big deal
it just all it just all works across the
board okay that was basically the gist
of the extensions that we're making so
far in the coming update I just did I
wanted to take a few minutes here and
just mention really quickly some
interesting talks dealing with basically
you know authoring content working with
the cloud and CDF in general these are
all interesting talks if you haven't
seen them before I recommend going to
see them and are there any questions at
all